hi everybody and welcome to our live Q&A
discussion with NASA and made in space
regarding 3d printing in space my name
is Adam and I'm the space physics
reporter here at wired science sunny
beautiful California and we've got a
bunch of people here who are ready to
take your questions and for this
discussion so why don't we go ahead and
introduce ourselves and we'll start over
on the Left most box with the Nutri once
you tell us your name and what you do
hi I'm will nutrit a and I work for NASA
space technology Mission Directorate and
I am one of nine principal investigators
for space technology responsible for
advanced manufacturing so we are really
excited about sorry about that and
you'll be hearing from Nicky soon and
emotions from made in space about this
great effort that we will be launching
in the summer of 2014 I will need sorte
and I work for NASA space technology
Mission Directorate and I am one of nine
principal investigators for space
technology responsible for advanced
manufacturing so we are really excited
sorry about that and you'll be hearing
from Nicky soon we will be launching in
the summer of 2014
I don't have anything
Opel's all right well we can land a
rover on Mars but sometimes we still
have some trouble here with sorry about
that that was a little screw up on our
side can we keep going with with Mike
why don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself sure and I'll try to only say
it once here okay we did everything
sounds good all right so yeah I'm Mike
Chen I am one of the cofounders of
maiden space
I helped have found the company in 2010
and where the we're basically making the
first 3d printer that will be going to
space and manufacturing the first
objects off of the surface of the earth
later this year cool and Nicky
hi there I'm Niki Werkheiser I'm the
NASA project manager for the 3d printing
and 0g ISS technology demonstration as
Loney mentioned it will be launching on
SpaceX 4 in August 2014 and we're very
excited this will be the first ready
printer ever and launched into space so
it's very exciting glad to be here
excellent and just a reminder for
anybody who's watching you can go to our
Google+ page there should be a link
below this screen and ask us any
questions during the Q&A we'll try and
field as many of them as we can from
that include Twitter but maybe just
start off with just to get the ball
rolling here 3d printers are really cool
they're great fantastic new technology
but maybe Mike you want to start us off
and tell us why would we would want to
send one into space yeah so it's a great
question and we could really even talk
about it for the whole time here but as
to why why send a 3d printer to space
you know really like originally a few
years ago when company started the idea
actually arose from talking to Dan berry
who's a 3-time astronaut and you know
he's been up there a few times and
playing with 3d printers down here and
really just observing how useful it
would be to be able to have objects put
into space without actually having to
launch them and so at the end of the day
that's really what it boils down to is
it boils down to being able to actually
put objects in space without having to
deal with the slow expensive complex
risky business of rockets what if you
could just put a file directly on the
computer and printed in space minutes
later so would it be something that you
would use maybe like in an emergency
situation or if there was something that
was going wrong up on the space station
you absolutely would I mean one thing
that we we've looked at a lot is how we
would be able to be ready for situations
like that they are one of our favorite
examples is of course the Apollo 13
example where they had to basically fit
a square peg into a round hole in order
to save Matt's lives and they were able
to
together a solution just kind of based
on what they had up there at the time
which is very fortunate we actually had
one of our interns use a Autodesk
software to cat up a solution that would
have also worked in the Apollo 13
situation printed it on one of the
printers in our lab and did the whole
thing in just a matter of hours now he's
hired obviously but yeah it could
definitely be used for emergency
situations but there's really a whole
wide range of other things you could use
it for science experiments aiding a
space exploration commercial satellite
projects there's really the list just
goes on and on I'm wondering for any of
you actually how did this out of this
partnership get started who reached out
to who whose idea was it to put a 3d
printer in space yeah Nicky might want
to talk a little bit about that you know
there's been some work going on at
Marshall for a while now since actually
even before we began developing this
printer Marshall has really been ahead
of the game on that and so that's why
we're working with Marshall but maybe
Nikki wants to talk a little bit that
that's that one yes I'd be happy to you
so actually in 1999 and one of our
principal investigator here at Ken
Cooper actually flew a 3d printer on the
parabolic flights effectually known as
the vomit comment and to test that out
back then so for us this feels like it's
been a long time coming and as you know
a space station is being has been built
for quite some time and we've been
excited about getting this up as an
actual payload made in space and NASA
had flown a series of the parabolic
flights to test in the microgravity just
to make sure that the prints would
actually be equitable to earth quality
prints like we do on the ground but you
can only get the short spurts of
microgravity when you're on the
parabolic flight so this will be the
first time in space that we can actually
complete an entire print in microgravity
so that's why we call it a technology
demonstration it's a very first step to
ensure that in the microgravity
environment the process is the same
there are no surprises and that would
change the quality of the print and then
we feel quite confident that that will
be it will be equitable to what we do on
the ground based on the parabolic
flights but yes we've been doing this
for quite
sometime and we feel like there are many
many uses of course the emergency case
comes up a lot and that's kind of the
exciting case but there's also the
standard everyday and people laugh
because they the crew will talk
sometimes about the losing a tool on
Space Station and we get a lot of
comments like how could you lose
something it's the space station where
could it possibly go but if you're like
me I've lived in my house for a few
years my closet if you go in my closet
you'll see how you can easily lose
things in a contained environment I'm
small parts especially tend to float off
and get sucked in by the filters you can
imagine at home if I drop something it
falls to the floor I know where to look
for it if it floats off on space station
then it does get sucked into these
filters never to be seen again so
there's a lot of lost parts broken parts
if they have to find multiple spares or
that take up a lot of mass and so there
are a lot of even everyday type
activities with science and payloads and
crew tools and things like that that
this will be a great capability for and
if I can add the 3d print project is a
it's a great example of collaboration
between NASA mission directorates as
well as industry this is a collaboration
between space tech Mission Directorate
as well as our human exploration
operations Mission Directorate which
houses our ISS and our AES programs
which are also investing in this and
made in space
the initial work with our flight
Opportunities program but they also have
a recent contract under our SBIR program
so it's a really great example of how
NASA comes together with industry and
does something really great both on the
technology side and the operation side
and nici is that a is that a 3d printed
part you've got in your hand there yes I
wanted to kind of kind of show a part
here that it may not look super exciting
and people say well what can you print
what can you do and something like this
it's kind of like you know it doesn't
look that exciting in person but it is
and this for example is a part that was
a filter extraction tool for a facility
that we have on Space Station and a
couple of years ago it got lost on Space
Station and the filters had expired the
certification for using that facility
and the crew can
use that facility so several of our
science payloads I think it was six or
eight months they had to wait for the
next launch to launch up this little
filter extraction tool we literally
could have uplink this file to space
station and had it printed within say an
hour turn around and you can imagine the
number of hours and days that we were
down in that facility the science that
we didn't get to do and for lack of
having this kind of capability so I just
wanted to show this it's just kind of
some some fun parts and real life real
use parts that we can get up there quite
quickly and another reason we think that
the astronauts are pretty excited yeah
like you said it I guess that some of it
is kind of mundane but they're really
necessary exactly yeah
so we have some questions here from our
audience the first one is from Fernando
Sanchez by the eV and I guess this is
something that probably everybody is
wondering maybe Mike you can talk about
this how does not having gravity affect
3d printing actually like it does it
make it easier harder what are the
challenges yeah yeah it's definitely a
common question and I'll try to say as
much of it as I can without saying
certain things that we we aren't
actually allowed to speak about but I
mean really when we when we first
started the company the idea was
actually not to create our own 3d
printer we really we saw the benefit of
having a 3d printer in space if there's
a lot of people watching now who are
familiar with like a concept of
shapeways or these service based 3d
printing businesses we just really
thought wow it would really help further
space exploration if we had a 3d printer
in space and so we started getting as
many sort of already available 3d
printers that we could get commercial
off-the-shelf and flying them on those
vomit comets and parabolic flights that
nikki was talking about and you know
between our engineers there was a lot of
debate in the beginning it was like well
some people thought they wouldn't
require too much tweaking some people
thought that they would but we actually
found out that none of them worked
right and what you really find out you
know at the end of the day is there's
you know somewhere around like 15 to 20
little things that you you have to
change in order to make 3d printing work
in space
some of the easy ones to sort of
visualize would be you know the
precision of the control that you would
need is a great example there are these
these pieces these parts are very highly
precise when they need to be
manufactured and if something's off by
even a little bit it can be weak inside
and without having the force of gravity
to kind of hold things in place it's
actually it can be really surprising how
bad things can really get you know
that's just just one of the things and
in addition to the gravity there's a
whole bunch of other things you have to
solve as well there's safety issues you
know commercial off-the-shelf 3d
printers emit harmful toxic gases that
you can't have up there so we ended up
learning over the years through really
part luck and purchased our amazing
engineering team that there's all these
changes that we had to make everything
from the gravity to the safety to the
off-gassing and we ended up having to
develop our own 3d printer from ground
up to work in space now we joke that if
we knew that we had to do that we
probably might not have even started
because it was a lot harder than we
thought but we're really excited to be
putting it up there well maybe yeah
lenitra maybe you could talk to this
about what what exactly the astronauts
would potentially be printing in space
like we saw Nikki's thing it looked like
it was made of plastic is that sort of
what you're thinking you would be
printing in space and how often would
you want to use it is this sort of like
an everyday thing you'd hope the
astronauts are using so Nick in our TAC
team we received a list of usual tools
and parts that the astronauts would use
or they may need resupply I think we
received a list of 13 so I those 13 will
do a total of 21 prints that will be
uploaded on the printer prior to launch
and then I'll let Nikki talk a little
bit about the exact tools and parts that
will print and the material that we'll
use yellow Anitra so and actually yeah
we'll do our first series the prints
will be that 21 and we'll start with
some some kind of things that might look
kind of boring or mundane you know our
tensile specimens and
strain specimens so we can test those on
the ground then we'll move on to what I
need to refer to that the crude tools
we've been working closely with the the
IV a the intra particular and tools
office down at Johnson Space Center that
supports the astronauts to get a list of
things that were kind of a the
no-brainers where would you start I did
want to point out if you can see this
when we first start this is the
feedstock so it looks very similar to
what and you would see like on your weed
eater we joke a lot about your weed
eater spool that's how it starts and
there are really two or three categories
of things that you can print first of
all everything about the most common
things that we have to launch right and
it cost of light to launch things into
space and we have to fly these spares
for the parts they really need multiple
wrenches all kinds of sample containers
and little clips and type things that
don't look super exciting but when you
have to pack you know 10 or 12 spares at
least of each of these items your math
adds up quickly but there's a whole
nother category that you have to think
about as well and that is a lot of
things that we designed to fly in space
and you really have to design those
around the launch loads so the structure
that you build it has to be quite robust
to survive actual loads of launch if you
can actually design these parts in space
this is where I get really excited and
it's really a whole mentality shift and
you can design completely differently so
even things like I don't know if you've
heard much about the Cube sets the Nano
sets they're to be enlarged um they've
launched quite a few from space station
now and with nanotechnology you can fit
a lot in those in those little suckers
so you can do science and you can do
communications you can do a plethora of
things with these cube sets and if you
could actually print the structure in
space instead of launching that and have
to design it to meet the launch loads
and you think how much space that
actually opens up for you so there are
things all sorts of things were just now
really starting and we need innovative
ideas and NASA is making calls and
creating challenges to get innovative
ideas for how would you design something
differently in space I don't have my
little wrench here with me right now but
for example you know I go to Home Depot
and I buy a wrench and everybody has an
image of a metal wrench that I get from
Home Depot but if I could design that
for for the application on Space Station
or on the Moon or Mars
I might design it different
on a 3d printer it might look flatter it
might look like a joke it might look
kind of like the the tools that my kids
played with when they were little
toddlers the little tool sets with the
hammers and the wrenches it may be
flatter and in a different shape but it
might work just fine for what we need
and this is really important on Space
Station we've extended the life of space
station and we have a lot of things that
are running out of certification and
things that we need to you a to fly up
but it's absolutely and I can't stress
this enough it's a critical technology
and capability if we're going to go to
moon or Mars or an asteroid and we're
really going to explore our solar system
this is something we cannot be reliant
on things launch from the ground every
time we need a new tool and we need our
astronauts to be able to design what
they need I'm kind of like a MacGyver on
the go so so there's multiple and I'd
add to that we like to think of it as
on-demand living so if you think about
the we may not can think about what the
astronauts may need a particular moment
but having the capability to be able to
print what they need as well be able to
design what they need changes the whole
logistical game of space exploration and
just to add piggyback on what Nikki said
this printer is a FDM modified FDM so
that means we'll be printing plastic
initially and then we'll also fly up an
optical scanner eventually that will
allow us to inspect the part after we
print it are all those pieces that you
showing it those are all 3d printed and
are those all things that are gonna be
or like things that the printer that's
going up on the space station could do
absolutely i'm yes and always make a
joke we talk about the ABS plastic but
it's what your Legos are made out of so
that's the comment comment terminology I
like to throw out but yes you know we've
got sample containers you know we can
print multiple you know parts that fit
together I've got a lot more fun parts
back in the lab that I could show but I
don't have them all with me and little
clips and you know things like little
fitted parts and you can also get very
creative you can actually build things
and you know your print volume but then
you
this thing so they can connect in
certain ways and so you can actually
build larger structures by connecting
them so we're trying to think of a lot
of fun and useful things that we can
print yeah and I just want to jump in
and add to that I think there's some
really good points made there I think
what what we're most excited about here
on the maiden space side in addition to
that is that you know is kind of
mentioned this is the first printer
we're sending up is a technology
demonstration but really based on the
technology that we've built here there's
going to be a second printer going up
after that which is going to be a
commercial facility where we're going to
actually be opening it up so that anyone
the world really can print things in
space and that really speaks to I think
something that Lanisha was touching on
earlier about how great of a partnership
this is between NASA private industry
you know we've been able to build this
technology working with NASA but now you
know we have a lot of people contacting
us who are saying you know we'd like to
put something in space we want to put
something on a space station you know
when when can you print for us right and
I think it's this is really really
important for furthering space
exploration you know if you look at how
amazing the potential is for space
exploration you not only could it hold
the you know the future of the human
race literally but it's also already the
backbone of so many of the essential
pieces of what we do here on earth today
GPS cell phones satellites all of this
space is so important but really up
until now it's been very very difficult
to access really only governments and
powers with billions of dollars could
even ever put something there and so one
of the things I'm most excited about is
once we have this printer there we're
going to be opening up access to space
to a whole new class of people
organizations in individuals and teams
on earth literally and I really mean
this for anyone who's tuned in right now
if there is something that you you do
want to put in space this really we
really want to make it possible so that
everybody has a chance to go ahead and
do that you might actually have the idea
right now for a better way that an
astronaut could do something up there
you might have a better idea for how
various things could be done and we want
to make it so that that global
collaboration that we're seeing with app
development and all of these other areas
that you know some fifteen-year-old in
Europe somewhere comes up with an idea
and suddenly it is able to get to the
top of the App Store why can't that same
kid be developing solutions for space
and when the it's really printers there
I really think that speaking of what
we're gonna print this can be most
exciting I think it's gonna be the
things that we haven't even thought of
yet that when people on earth really
wake up and realize that wow now they
actually can put things into space in an
affordable and fast way that's when the
innovation is really going to take off
and we're gonna get the developments we
need to further space exploration and
Michael as a student getting access to a
CAD file and up linking it directly to
the printer and printing something in
zero-g on the space station I think
that's very powerful
add to that - we'll have we'll have some
of the files and that we're gonna be
printing in space available here on the
ground
I'm there's an open gov initiative to
have open source information so anyone
on the ground say my daughters were
excited about this when they were doing
science fair they were saying the mommy
if I have access to a 3d printer I can
print the exact thing on on the ground
and show my friends that - charts are
going to print space and that's
absolutely true I'd also like to add and
NASA is really trying to clear the path
for this commercialization effort our
end goal is that eventually once all
this happens in main space has the
commercial printer on orbit
that NASA is actually a customer of that
printer and we have the ISS is a
National Lab and I encourage folks to to
google that and see the cool things that
we're doing with our space station and a
lot of people know that it's up there
and they know we're doing probably some
really cool stuff and that this
commercialization and it's really a
national asset that we want to utilize
I'm effectively and efficiently so
ultimately we want to be a customer of
this as well NASA isn't looking to be
the one to build the printers but to
enable the path into in to utilize the
printers cool we actually have a
different another different question
over here from destory Teeter and I
think some of the things that you guys
are talking about people might be
excited
will there be a chance of live streaming
or tweeting from the 3d printer in space
like are people going to be able to see
stuff come out of the out of the printer
somewhere on NASA TV we actually will be
recording and the print I will begin a
lot of science data from that but we
actually are planning to have an twit
the printer itself to have a Twitter
account and so we're hoping the printer
itself will be tweeting and receiving
tweets and we can kind of see where it
goes from there we do have some
educational outreach and some stem
activities that we'd like to work with
schools and other outlets and some cool
challenges that everybody needs to kind
of be listening out for and that will be
announced in the near future so we're
really excited about that but yes we do
plan for the printer to have a Twitter
and I'm sure a Facebook account as well
so I had to be interactive and we will
be having videos of the actual printing
while they're taking place I have
another another question here from
Travis Nelson Hummel and maybe this is
also something I'm wondering it how and
we can talk sort of about how how things
are moving in the future but how
far-fetched is the idea of sending a 3d
printer to an asteroid to the moon or
tars and having it build a space station
or you know tools and some base for the
astronauts to live to live in yeah it's
a it's a great question I'm sure we'll
all have something to say there I guess
the the biggest thing that I wanted to
say in response is that really that's
why we're doing all of this you know the
when we started looking at how to put 3d
printers in space we're very excited
about the prospects of really changing
the way that things were done on the
space stations but as a company we we
really are focused on enabling those
bigger space exploration goals kind of
like we're mentioned you know going to
asteroids moon Mars building entire
space stations things like that and so
we focused the entire time on developing
technology that would be possible to use
inside the space station but also have
major applications in all of those other
areas so we view this as a very real and
step towards those further out goals
that's kind of what's amazing about 3d
printing as a technology is it's so
versatile the same thing that can print
a little wrench like this may also be
able to print a lot of other much more
complicated and larger and more
progressive things so that's absolutely
the focus and this sort of step of
manufacturing the first thing in space
at all and then the next 10 20 30 and
however many after that on station is is
a very important milestone on the way to
those future steps both technologically
and just societally so NASA as a whole
we've looked at an entire road map of
the future of manufacturing in space and
we look at it from a point of view of
building the capability so that we can
explore deeper and deeper space so we
look at the International Space Station
we look at ground-based and we look at
other planetary services that include
the asteroid as different testing and
proving grounds and platforms that first
we start with the 3d printer on zero-g
then you know as a plastic that maybe we
look at metals and then we look at a
recycler and then we'd go external to
the space station and we look at how do
we you use what we've learned from the
3d printer and now starting using that
to the larger structures or being able
to function on other planetary surfaces
and then using those resources or
in-situ resources from another planetary
surface to afford us an infrastructure
that we can explore other parts of the
universe so if I could add to that just
a little because this is a very exciting
area and so the term that's kind of
being coined is in space manufacturing
and like lenitra and my clothes referred
to it's really a whole suite of
capabilities and the 3d printer inside
space station is just a very very first
step and as lynitra mentioned we have
things like external imagine if we had
and the micrometer everybody seen and
maybe gravity imagine if you had a
micrometeorite hit on station currently
we don't have a really a way to do an in
space repair and imagine if we could
structure light
scanned they have handheld scanners
which Lanisha referred to earlier that
we plan to fly soon could actually scan
the hit and then you could
reverse-engineer a CAD model out of that
and then print a patch in addition to
that I don't know if you've heard much
about the contour crafting or the
additive construction and if you google
that today you'll see some articles pop
up and we're in China for example
they've been building temporary housing
that's a capability that's not science
fiction that's a capability that exists
today on the ground it's a very exciting
when you can imagine in a case like a
natural disaster with FEMA or our
military out in a remote area if you
could build things like landing pads and
remote shelters you can imagine on Mars
or if you needed a radiation protection
habitat and as a nature mentioned for
our space exploration you would use the
Institute so you would use the Regulus
from whatever and a terrestrial beam you
might be on but on the ground maybe you
could use sand so there's a lot of cool
technologies and that are on the ground
that now at NASA and companies like
maiden space I'm can leverage there are
things we have to tweak and do a little
differently for the in space
applications but we are keeping up with
the current technologies and leveraging
those where we can and there's also
things like recycling and we hope to
find station of today as a matter of
fact and I think there might be an
announcement for the 2014 phase one a
small business innovation awards and we
had put one out for recyclers we think
the next key step would be to show that
you could turn this part back into the
the feedstock and then reuse that
feedstock for exploration you can
imagine how key that would be and that's
also something we could use on the
ground for if we have printers in our
home which I think a lot of us will
shortly and so we're excited about
looking into that type of a
demonstration as well yeah and I just
want to throw one other thing on the end
there which is tying back to what I said
before of just really reminding people
that with these 3d printers on the space
station you are going to be able to
design things and impact space
exploration right so even if we're doing
something small on the space station
there are experiments that you can do
there that are very relevant to say
printing something on an asteroid right
so if you're interested in the idea of
what could you do on an asteroids we can
prove a lot of those ideas and test a
lot of those ideas with what we're doing
on station now and again being able to
have that like more global open access
to ideas right maybe now a high school
team can think of an experiment that is
simulating something about an asteroid a
3d printed and we do it just having that
so much more open to the world is really
going to accelerate our progress towards
being able to do it say with an actual
asteroid and I would add that you know
we're sending up a 3d printer a box but
printing on another planetary surface
would look totally different it would be
a very automated very robotic Whisperer
ahead of some sorts so to stretch your
imagination of what what that would look
like and you have to start from
somewhere to establish that capability
and I think the 3d print effort really
triggers that thought process to allow
us to think what would that look like
what would being able to use additive
manufacturing or some other form of in
space manufacturing to to create
infrastructure on other planetary
surfaces it's look totally different
than what we could imagine and you think
about an integrated system to for like
printable electronics really hot area so
the integrated system would have all of
these capabilities where you could
verify the part meet specifications and
you have printable electronics and the
autonomy and the software and so it's
it's very exciting and we really hope to
hear back from people out there and in
universities and schools and the general
public because this is a very innovative
area and one that we feel strongly we
can interact with the public in and it's
a different way of thinking it's
somewhat a mentality shift and we look
forward to hearing from from folks
across the country yeah I guess I was
gonna ask you if you could maybe
describe to us what what this would
actually look like when let's say it's
developed obviously this is fiction far
out there but if you wanted to build a
house would you have to drop a house
size printer down down there on the moon
let's say
well those are things that we're looking
at today lynitra can talk to but like I
said the technology on the ground exists
today it's one that's evolving quickly
because I think there's a real-world
need for that um and the answer is
really no and there's some really cool
technologies out there now where and it
doesn't have to be the size of a house
to print a house you can actually print
a piece by piece and build on those
structures autonomously with robots and
there's there's all kinds of and that's
where I was really bringing up the
innovative ideas and it's it's it
doesn't have to be one plus one equals
two you can actually take advantage of
integrated systems and robotics and
autonomy and to actually come up with
new and different ways of doing this in
a smaller package actually Nikki I'm
also just wondering you mentioned and
maybe Mike can talk about this as well
that you guys who have had tests on the
on the Vomit Comet and can you can you
describe that a little bit more I'm also
just wondering like you've got 30
seconds this thing is printing it's in
the middle of something and oh your 30
seconds are up to have to grab the
machine before it's gonna crash up to
the floors
yeah so it's know it is bolted down so
you don't have to worry about that it's
it's it's flies in a parabola so what
you get is you get yeah about you know
30 seconds or so of zero-g and then it
pulls into 2g and that the 2g is
actually the part that most people's
stomachs have a problem with but no what
we actually did was to actually make it
easier on ourselves we started making
the printer so that it would actually be
able to print all the way throughout the
entire parabola so anywhere from zero to
two or actually anywhere so it's
something we don't actually talk about
that much but since you brought it up I
mean yeah what we actually have
developed is not just a zero-gravity
printing technology but a gravity
independent printing technology so we
actually just let it print all the way
through and in our final iterations you
look at the final prints and you
couldn't even tell it's like whether was
zero or two or anywhere in between the
part would be indistinguishable so yeah
do you guys know what the the very first
thing you're going to print on the space
station is when it gets up
they're in August so we we are playing
around with you know a few different
concepts there is one that's kind of on
our minds right now but I guess Nikki
are we are we talking about that
publicly at this point or well well as I
mentioned earlier that should have
brought some money but the very first
parts and look kind of mundane and
trivial to the common laymen I because
they are things like tensile specimens
and the key objective here is to get
those samples I will learn a lot with
the camera recording the print and
calculators are being laid in real time
and but then we'll also be bringing
those back to the ground and doing
detailed ground analysis so that's kind
of the science II and we get excited
about it not everyone thinks is that
exciting and but then after that we do
have several tools one thing I'll
mention is like replacement parts for
the printer and there there are certain
components of the printer itself and
I'll let Mike if you want to talk about
a little bit more that if we need to
replace those I'm just normal wear and
tear just like your the printer on the
ground we want to be able to print some
of those replacement parts and be our
first kind of customer and user and Mike
if you want to talk more about that feel
free yeah yeah sure so yeah we we
designed the printer itself to have a
number of components inside that are
actually 3d printed right we sort of
wanted to prove that you know really you
could you could have real space hardware
with 3d printed parts I mean it's
something that we know but it's not you
know it's not quite clear to everyone so
we took every opportunity to make quite
a number of really important parts
inside our 3d printer actually 3d
printable and the printer itself is
actually going to be able to print its
own replacement parts to a certain
extent and some of the first things
we're gonna be printing are going to be
those actual replacement parts and if
all goes as planned we're actually gonna
maybe even try to install them back in
the printer and to show that it was
actually able to repair itself well I'm
gonna take one one last question here
from our audience this one is from Jared
Phipps who asks if there are any new
technologies that we believe we could
see in zero-g only that are completely
different than than what we would
have here on earth with 3d printing sure
yeah I think Nikki was about to go I say
and then excited about it yes absolutely
yeah we do get excited about that and
the answer is there absolutely could be
and one of the reasons we do call this a
technology demonstration is just what we
were saying they can fly the parabolic
flights but we can't complete an entire
print during that microgravity burst on
a parabolic flight so truly what's
really exciting for us kind of geeky
folks on the material side of this as
well is is we don't know for sure what
in microgravity might happen we might
actually see some improvements and the
way the printer is designed you know we
don't have convection in space for
example and so they're back when we were
doing a lot of crystal growth we saw a
lot of improvements in the way the
crystal structure and was built and so
we can actually possibly see that as
well we just don't know and that's that
is the exciting part about a technology
demonstration as I mentioned earlier
it's not just the microgravity aspect of
might we see something different it's
how we can design differently we we
might be I am positive that we are going
to come up with and you the public
helped us come up with new and
innovative ways of making stuff in space
that we've never been able to do just
because of the way we have to launch it
and so the answer is yes we absolutely
could find some cool materials aspects
of this that make it different than
printing on the ground but it's an
absolute hundred percent certainty that
we will find new things to print and use
in a different way in the microgravity
environment but I would just add just
from I'm sorry Mike
just from the the mere redesign made in
space did several perfect fights and
they've had to come up with their own
design just starting from that point
we've we've added to the to the
knowledge base of 3d printing from print
heads to you know how you know how's the
polymer going to flow out so I think you
know credit is is due to made in space
for just taking that risk and being
innovative to design their own printer
yeah well thanks lynnie German kind of
like I said earlier we actually didn't
even set out to do it and it was a very
interesting road
but yeah it's been it's it's it you're
all right now we actually have developed
a number of technologies for 3d printing
that are I think going to be really
useful you know in space but also down
here on earth I know we're almost at a
time but I just wanted to reiterate kind
of Nikki's last point because I think
it's the most solid takeaway to that
question of what is different about what
you can print in space and how 3d
printing works I mean if you've ever
designed anything to be 3d printed
you're doing engineering you've
definitely thought about the fact that
there's going to be gravity right so
you're going to have to design the part
to support its own weight even worse if
it has to be launched it has to support
much more than its own weight also the
vibrations and everything like that just
close your eyes one time and imagine
what it would be like to design
something that had that didn't ever have
to support any weight at all and you end
up with these completely different kinds
of structures that really could be
incredibly beneficial in a lot of ways
and 3d printing in space is most likely
the only way to make those structures
you see y'all help base and help us coin
a term well you know we've been throwing
around terms like zero-g structures but
we're really and trying to create a term
that is something that you can print
with microgravity that you couldn't do
on earth so I joke around with the guys
at main space and I say okay well how
would we print our ground samples how do
we know it works and and and the point
is and you know it doesn't work on the
ground and that's why you're doing it in
space for the zero-g type structures and
we've been playing around we'd like some
of those might eat and it's a really fun
dialogue to have so I encourage all and
I think we'll have some of our contact
information out there and feel free to
contact us with with fun cool ideas on
or different ways of explaining zero-g
structures and I know we're about to
wrap up but I just want it to NASA does
so many things everyone looks at NASA as
being the full agency but we do so many
things to advance technology but both
for Space Exploration as well as for
daily life and 3d printing as we all
know it's been around for 20-25 years
and there's a new resurgence of 3d
printing and this weekend NASA
had a booth at the USA science and
engineering festival and space Tech had
a 3d printer and there are so many young
kids that came to explore the 3d printer
and I think this is an opportunity with
our 3d printing in zero-g to really
impact the next generation of science
and engineers and so I think if a
setting aside the technology that we're
going to develop I think we're making us
a real big impact on our younger
generation and I think 3d printing is
that technology that really will help
influence that awesome we are pretty
much almost out of time here
I just wanted to maybe ask you guys a
simple question if you I don't know if
any of you have an answer to this but
how much were you inspired by
replicators on Star Trek with this
technology well I can say a hundred
percent you know I definitely grew up
watching all that stuff and we actually
had rod Roddenberry stopped by our
office not too long ago who's the son of
Gene Roddenberry the creator of Star
Trek and we had the amazing moment where
he actually came into our lab and put
his hand on our printer and actually
said T are over a hot so that was a
pretty cool moment for all the Star Trek
fans out there of course it didn't make
the T yet but that'll be for a future
future version of the Turner but yes
absolutely inspired yeah yeah miniature
Mickey absolutely hey I think I think
it's obvious we hear that a lot and this
definitely aged along the lines of the
replicator we're trying to make that
real I also think there's BIGBANG guys
might like this as well
definitely I'm a die-hard Trekkie and so
when I think of this I think of the next
the next step of actually for
transporting ourselves to a planetary
surface this is just a starting point so
I think we really get very excited about
this and I hope that you see that when
we
about 3d printing because we think it's
the best thing since some talk well
thanks everybody for for joining us for
sitting through some of our technical
difficulties some construction here at
Wired's offices as well if you want to
find out more information we've got
information about both this NASA effort
and made in space on our Google+ page
and you can try and contact any of the
folks that you've talked to today so
thanks very much thanks for the
opportunity we're here and back thanks
everyone
all right bye-bye